what do i worry about i worry about  brand control  my brand is is huge now right and one  thing i fight with every day i want to  make sure i don't dilute the brand  i don't do anything make any major  mistakes because  any mistake will hurt your brand and so  those are the things that keep me up at  night  just making sure my brand remains strong  and so that's a good message for all  these young  men and women watching your show is make  sure that  your brand is everything and you will  always be able to make money if your  brand is strong  even if you go bankrupt if your brand is  strong  you'll be able to still make some money  donald trump proved that he bounced  right back  look where he is today you know he went  through that phase came right back  because he kept the brand strong and  that's important